[MUSIC PLAYING]
This episode was proudly
made possible by Subaru.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, there's a term
that I really like
called the adrenaline hack.
And that's this
idea that we have
co-opted biological systems--
in this case, alarm systems--
and then used them
towards cultural ends.
So for example, we
get an adrenaline rush
when our over-active amygdala
responds to a perceived danger
and has to decide whether to
fight, neutralize, or flight
and run away to survive.
It's a biological alarm system
inducing anxiety and fear
so that we get out of
a dangerous situation.
But the fact that, as
modern cultural beings
now that inhabit
landscapes of imagination,
we've created systems,
rhetorical technologies that
co-opt these biological
alarm systems
and place them in safe contexts
so that we can experience
our bio-chemical signature
or the surging multiplicity
of emotions to which we are
privy to in a safe setting.
For example, watching
a scary movie,
going on a roller
coaster ride, skydiving.
Your brain is
telling you, danger.
The adrenaline rush is
the one of impending doom
and yet, the fact that you know
that you're in a safe space,
allows you, on a mental
level, to be aware
that you're not going to die
and therefore enjoy the wonder
and amazement and the
hardly bearable ecstasy
of direct energy exploding
from your nerve endings,
as Timothy Leary would say.
So think about that the next
time you skydive, or you're
at a scary movie, and
you're like, all right,
let me experience
the full spectrum
of human emotion
in a safe setting.
It's unbelievable.
And it's the adrenaline
hack and it's
what makes us such
creative beings.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Be sure to check out
Second Chance Subaru
at revision3.com/subaru.